hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
we're going into the graveyard which if
you remember from the original series is
the first place we ever came from the
very first so we're kind of going back
hello
I got damnit oh no what the flowers ate
me
it just got back wait it didn't ruin an
ending I still got the available ending
so maybe I'm okay
hmm oh oh I remember it I do I remember
that in my crazier mother that familiar
nobody used to look like now what it
originally was way back in that day cool
cool it's also cool so I'm going to
assume that the nasty plants are just
something I shouldn't go near and
they're just bad and they've been me not
necessarily that I did anything bad
Lulla plenty flower
okay repin woo own good oh my door
spider on a bone go fetch
go fetch it off that cliff go off that
cliff ha Spidey boo alright fine then
god the music is so cool it's a role I
love it
hello anybody here and I just will hit
you real close I touch you was weird
will hide what the hell what are you I
chopped you off huh I don't like the way
that's undulating I don't often get to
use the word undulating but I think it's
only appropriate okay there's another
one why are you earth worm bastards
undulating around here okay I think
that's my answer and my cue to leave oh
that's good
maybe who knows honestly okay so
with that blood coupler and what was
that that just land by the back of my
head well there's so many people
screaming around here I don't like it I
do not like this
hello knock knock whoa what did I get I
got matches they're slightly bloody but
I got them what does that mean and I
burned this camper and then okay like
I'm at high earthworm how are you doing
so we won but okay alright but that did
something so now I have matches we know
what that means don't know why this
plots of blood is there but it's good oh
hi I didn't even know you were here
oh I can light this candle Oh once again
there's a key okay once again I didn't
have all the pieces of the puzzle I
didn't know there was even another way
to go are you crying are you crying
blood I mean I guess you're blown are
doing bolted with crying but are you
crying blood more importantly this is
what I didn't mean to do that
I'm sorry sorry I kept doing it after I
did it where's oh hi miss kita here no
Keith Lee the other what we're making
progress here alright so I'm gonna wait
there's another
I don't know what the screaming it is
not good you want to flower there there
we go how's that oh you love it oh it's
great hi were you screaming lady are you
doing here my child have you come here
in search of the source of our problem
that's a fool's errand death left this
place a long time ago we're not able to
get away from this dream without death
you see we have to die here in order to
get back to the real world
sadly death has not visited anyone for a
long time even those who are hunted down
by the scary monsters funny that
immortality would cause people to summer
suffer nothing but us is real here this
whole world is built of our imagination
how do I know you're real unfortunately
it's worse every moment people are
scared of their own shadows so their
minds make up new monsters the dream is
turning into an even worse nightmare
it's a vicious circle you don't have to
worry about me my child compared to the
others I can take care of myself
I've been here for a long time then I've
learned some tricks like what if you
still want to keep searching you should
check out the Crypt you may find some
clues there but the door is locked with
some kind of special lock I have no idea
how to open it look for the clues in the
crypt okay will do
thanks lady you're so nice nice cankles
okay you carry on I'll be I'll be back
maybe I helped him this with a pickaxe
no okay
I'm gonna try to okay I gotta open some
sort of crypt here about this key yes
okay hello
I oughta saved so something bad might
happen but I also I could have picked
the flower with the walls that would
have been smart but it didn't give me a
bad end so I guess it's okay I don't
know what else is here anybody in the
coffin anybody's using it hello shovel
I've got one already but you know I just
thought again member so I got a glove
now I'd love that guy can a pickaxe that
guy gotta be somebody that glove here I
got
[Music]
oh hi also hello rat you want to be
burnt alive you're gonna get shoveled
want to get boned somebody can I do
nothing to you oh okay alright fine then
so you're guarding that is something
else gotta be something I can do to try
to entice that rat away from this right
whoa I didn't even think about that why
did I need to do that what did I need to
break that is open now why did I need to
break that there's nothing down there
oh why am i digging into this grave
hello sir are you not dead or you know
you're not dead hi hello welcome to the
party ah mind if I kick his head
you're you you sickness and a thank you
kind sir
oh thank you get back in the ground now
get back in the ground get back in there
alright would you like a nice tasty hand
no can I leave this on the box or
something why do I have a hand
well you would you like a hand Oh gross
what was the point of that gonna burn
you now who dumb no you're gonna be
occupied I better come back Oh spider
poop rotten meat
would you like to run me near anything
to skull now Oh would you like a skull
in return no all right fine then so this
skull something's got to be done about
this skull maybe the skull goes as ah ah
but not all the way there
bone ah I need another bone ah I get it
I gots it I good - all right sir can I
have another bone hey you got bones to
spare come on man stop being so stingy
oh maybe when the spiders done eating
can I have this thank you
you take care now you take care alright
you dick here now alright bye alright
Bob
there you go I'm in hell yeah the Grim
Reaper I light this candle
shooty hi there
autumns been a motor Ian dude I don't
know what that means and I don't think I
pronounced it correctly but okay ah okay
that's nice it's dark now why is it dark
now what did that do what did this do oh
it's night now oh I need to collect the
stars that's beautiful
oh that's beautiful hmm we would try to
end the night somehow what fine I find a
way to end the night I didn't even read
what you said not in this world waiting
is not enough in this world so I know
what I need to do it's obvious I've been
looking at the Stars all my life I'm
gonna stop hi buddy I forgot you there
also who put these candles here cuz I
certainly didn't that okay there's got
to be a star there but that was only
four gotta be another star that I missed
somehow but take this interface with you
or maybe a star that's not necessarily
in the sky maybe there's a star
somewhere else
you know you know I'm saying in the
picture oh wait no back back back back
where do I go back
back back back back back in this picture
there was a star I remembered that's why
that pictures there that's why and now
all the stars are there a sweet little
pentagram that's a hole I don't want to
stick my hand in oh good Oh No thank you
I'm busy in here privacy please you stay
out hi hello I don't want any okay all
right goodbye
I think oh my god what did it take hey
that was mine you dick
oh you oh you dick it's locked now lady
you've met her haven't you who she was
here the hiding place must have hidden
something very important something so
precious that it brought death here oh
my god what does that mean it took the
skull it took this Oh Oh what the hell
have done what is that bad it just
erased it as if reality doesn't matter
it just erased it
please one erase me end my torment wake
me up from this nightmare thank you what
the hell what the hell what the hell oh
ah good evening good evening good
evening how you be are you been out of
the family please don't be scared
awful things are going on out there but
it's nice and safe here I see you have
matches with you don't play with them
here they're very dangerous you can burn
yourself or Gaza fire better give them
back to your mom or dad anyway do you
have parents I don't but my friend who
used to have them he asked me to watch
over them they're sleeping dug deep in
the ground it's not too much work with
them but it'd be easier if I could have
my own body someone stole it and now I'm
left alone with this oh it wasn't very
nice you help me look for my little body
and go with you it'll be fun I just have
to detach myself from this silly body I
borrow your scissors from
thank you so much can you leave me alone
come back in a moment okay that's weird
Oh too soon too soon all right I'll see
you in a bit
okay all right cool all right cool Oh
Nelly right what about this lady you
found part of an eraser this is it death
has erased people from this world with
it if we could just find the other parts
you have achieved a lot please keep on
searching all right fine see if these
gun chopping his head off from his body
you're done you need to be alone okay I
will see you then oh this is open okay I
didn't know this was open oh all right
then
hello okay I let the bug out that's nice
okay got a jar that's nice there's a
heart here hi are you good
all right you kidding is there any
reason for me to be here looking at that
up close like it's not cuz there no
reason for that oh hi oh that's
horrifying
oh that's real weird that is really
weird
oh that's horrifying
I painted a door with the blood and that
worked somehow yeah hey fighters like me
a Nazi plans great didn't mean to do
that one but that is what it is so
anyway that's the end of chapter three
oh my god this game is awesome a little
bit oh it's such a good point and click
puzzle I'm so deep I love it anyway so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will continue on with this I don't
know where we're going next I think the
forest it said but it's getting really
cool so let me know we thought down the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]